he has just been voted
online maker with the greatest
potential by the next conference jan beckers brings
game manufacturers, players and advertisers
together and earns money himself in the process his
berlin hitfox group is constantly growing
we earn money when the players
find the games they want and the
games publishers earn money accordingly
and we then get a
share of what the players have the
15-year-old now understands i don't know
but it's also a very
complicated value chain
for me it's a market that has doubts for those who
are growing entrepreneurially
on the other hand the brand is easy going  it
's fun
nice people and in this respect it's a very
good industry maybe don't
feel very comfortable basically i play a
tablet at night before
I go to sleep or something like that i play from time to
time otherwise maybe when i
'm sitting in a taxi on my cell phone apart from it
I've been more focused on
it  building up this company is
so when I was young i felt like playing
strategy games and 15 or
so i always either
built something or conquered something and it is
exactly this pattern that you can now find in
a very productive
way as an entrepreneur.
i always build there too  something on it is
multiplayer capable team a
certain value you can see how from
the world every company i
have founded has gotten bigger and
insofar it gives me
a certain joy
to see exactly this growth
and when things go well then it has too
still nice sausage so think that's my
main